hello fellow youtuber Michael Vsauce
here
awkward handshakes it's a topic that's
very important to me you know people
pick all kinds of topics to devote their
life to maybe make the planet a better
place my vow for my life is to stop
awkward handshakes I've started a
charity organization stop awkward
handshakes org and so far we got a lot
of supporters who are feeling the same
issue as I have of the pure cringe of an
awkward handshake we've all had one so
to lessen the blow for all of you that's
suffering out there here at awkward
handshakes stop them at org we're going
to laugh at other people having awkward
handshakes because that helps to release
a little bit of that stress that you're
going through don't don't don't worry I
know when you're going through it's
going to be okay now this one so many
people send to me when it dropped and I
got a mitt it's pretty funny okay let's
watch Trump's kid I swear it's going to
be the new jacksepticeye one day my name
is Jackson what is happening here can we
deconstruct this I want to understand
where it ran wrong she goes in for the
half fun kid gets wrecked look at that
face look at that face that's the face
of absolutely obliterated the kid knows
you know it's bad enough Trump is his
father but this this is too much being
humiliated by her mother he won't stand
for it
she strikes again now shaking he's
infuriated he knows he needs to make a
move he does the jacksepticeye balls
move but very effective actually no he
looks like a [ __ ] insane person I
even sympathize with this kid I'm like
dude this kid's gotta have some issues
you know when I was a kid no cringe
whatsoever oh I'm really cool trust me I
am very cool I was even cooler as
younger action
you know I took down my cool let's Nevel
just so since we're on the Trump topic
of handshakes you know he's been in the
public eye a lot lately and a lot of
handshakes don't really seem to work out
for him or maybe they are let's watch
the result might shock you why am i
click baiting you mid video that doesn't
make any sense
this one I don't understand it says
funny and racist excuse me no those
things do not match you cannot
disgusting I'm gonna tell Wall Street
Journal about this right now
[Music]
so what what is so funny in races I
don't assignment
ah I don't know I think I read somewhere
that he's not supposed to shake the hand
yeah he had something in his a hand so
he's like I don't although I think that
guy put that thing in his hand so he can
blue trump up I think that's what
happened I mean you're gonna easily just
put it in the other side but he's like
you know what that's not racist that's
just him not liking Trump good-good
zinger there I would say that was a good
zinger look at Trump's face hair you
can't really make out the pixel but if
you zoom in closer can we get a facial
scan on that face that's right he
absolutely just got savaged 100% Oh
handshakes oh you how can you get this
so wrong thousands of years of social
interaction and we still haven't gotten
past this have you opened your eyes yet
go and donate to stop awkward handshakes
org you can also donate directly through
my PayPal trust me it's legit it's a
legit charity we take ourself very
seriously all the money goes to the
organization moving on thank you
oh it doesn't show this might seem like
a normal handshake to you but have you
opened your eyes yet let's look at that
another angle damn can't just look you
don't do that you can't I mean you can I
think we all can learn something from
Trump here actually I didn't think I
would say that but I was an excellent
show of how to do a boss handshake
honestly he's such an [ __ ] that's
such a dick move he's basically saying
hey my penis is bigger than yours oh
okay
but this this it's just the beginning
I'm sure you've seen this one
we have America and we have Japan and we
have what I would like to call a sexual
interaction taking place through purely
by a handshake ice why did you hear that
shall we shake Trump knew it was coming
shall we shake this face says yes yes we
shall
mr. prime minister oh my god little did
he know what he invited himself to
he just a hand slap I don't know what's
up for that he blocked the pole very
excellent block of the pole prime mr.
prime minister you blocked the pole not
a lot of people can pull that off it's
laughing a little bit to hide the
awkwardness I can really you know that's
a that's also a really good move look at
me he wants to maintain eye contact he's
trying to make it less awkward but he
keeps going he's like hey look that was
the climax pretty much why is this so
funny to me I have no idea from you know
being the gentleman he has to compliment
for having strong hands wait the
infamous Donald Trump I didn't know this
is a thing it comes what's gonna happen
oh oh isn't too bad
Oh what no I don't I don't see it I
don't see it all right now I'm just
happy trump is present so I can see him
do more handshakes yes this is very
fascinating this is good for research
for our charity but anyway I'm not here
to just talk about mr. Trump I'm here to
talk about awkward handshakes that's
where my passion is that's where my
heart is and it's an important cost that
I don't think a lot of people realize
so I said this before and I'll say it
again we should vow surely you can never
[ __ ] up about that's all we should do
just bow there's no it's foul put it's
full it's foul proof it's foolproof
shut up thank you very much for your
thoughts and again I look forward to
seeing you play on the Sun on the Monday
actually and and I guys it's back to you
he shook with the wrong hand obviously
it's awkward disgusting this man needs
to be killed
I'm sorry I know that see might seem a
little harsh but this charity is not
[ __ ] around okay no more Hank shakes
you get one strike okay you [ __ ] it up
once and you're done you know I may have
[ __ ]
but that doesn't matter
so thinking forward to the Navi game now
again best of five Oh what we're going
for work I wasn't ready to go oh no same
oh I wasn't ready that's too bad it's
already done my damage is done I was
making an expression well I wasn't going
for a handshake I was making expression
thank you for adding me to a cringe
compilation you [ __ ] [ __ ] he try to
save it no no no no just no I'm sorry
you're both gonna get do you both gonna
have to get executed I'm sorry all the
adjustments they needed and wanted the
whole thing very close it was ghost and
stone dark dark rings immediate classic
oh [ __ ] he's going in for the roughest I
am doing the handshake oh no how do we
how do we fix this oh [ __ ] ah Sh ah ah
if you get in that situation I have
thing installing my tooth that I can
bite on it injects poison in my
bloodstream I will be dead
I'd be cuffing of my own saliva and
bubbles and I'll be eventually be dead
within a couple seconds you know you can
buy this package by now you can get the
deluxe model which has grills in it stop
awkward handshakes out oh I get it I'm
plugging my show a little bit too much
I'm sorry I'm not a sellout okay it's
something I believe they punished buddy
gets the does finish apostle take in the
game there it is again
big guys like [ __ ] you [ __ ] me
you [ __ ] me so hard the fat more so
you know if you're gonna be on a gaming
event how about you do this okay after
the game is over fist bump and then what
you do after you win you go in for the
handshake and basically the other guy
well
- just died hope you enjoyed this video
if you did and leave a like and turn off
the Adsense cuz apparently my ad revenue
was dropping because youtube doesn't
like me anymore so if you could just I
don't know do something I don't know
I'm a greedy greedy bastard and I need I
need that extra so if you could if you
couldn't drop the ad not bad that
Adsense no bad block so if you can if
you can drop the ad block that would
just be that would be great thing thank
you thank you very much
and brofist